bhangra destroy that country
the battle that's long been brewing a
gearbox software is finally ready for
release but we won't be able to issue a
verdict for another few days I recently
played throughout a boring story driven
cooperative missions in a controlled
offline setting so while I need more
time to play the competitive multiplayer
I can't offer some concrete impressions
of battle borns campaign core gameplay
and jam-packed character roster
ostensibly the game is the first person
shooter but only a handful of its 25
heroes actually wheel guns several have
no ranged attacks at all the opting
instead for melee weapons such as
ancient war axes futuristic atanas or
massive mechanical fists still others
function mainly as support units
absorbing damage healing allies and
stripping away enemy shields the variety
of mechanics on offer is at first
totally overwhelming if you roll into
battle without reading up on your
characters weapons and abilities you'll
frequently find yourself saying I have
no idea what I just did however I found
that once I got to know a character i
generally fell into a pretty predictable
gameplay loop
I am sustain your Alina characters
distinct skills give them a natural role
within the chaos melee attackers charge
right in healers follow up behind and
try to keep them alive snipers off
recover from a distance and so on I
ended up relying mostly on mid range
damage dealers which meant repeatedly
draining my clip into bad guys deploying
my special attacks as soon as their
cooldown timers expired and retreating
to let my shield recharge whenever
necessary battle bourn's AI enemies are
for the most part mindless Potter that
simply charged straight at you so I
never really needed to change it my
tactics especially since my teammates
were able to cover all the bases I
couldn't as a result battle bourn's
action fields not quite mindless but
certainly fast in arcade far more
frantic run and gun than strategic stop
and pop in some ways this repetition
made the gameplay feel wrote but with a
full five man team the action remains
surprisingly satisfying enemy stream in
from all directions before colorful
bursts of energy explode from your
allies to meet the charge you've dash at
extreme speeds around obstacles and dive
on the cartoonish villains with
invigorating ferocity together your team
beats a boss to a pulp so efficiently he
can't even counter-attack there's enough
going on that I always felt empowered
and entertaining and when I grew tired
of throwing out the same old supers I
just switched to a new character to
start fresh it's possible this character
hopping approach won't be enough to
sustain players interest in the long run
especially given the relative simplicity
of the gameplay once you surmounted
characters initial learning curve but in
theory the competitive multiplayer is
hero on hero matchups should force
players to find creative ways to utilize
the skills that become routine when
fighting off batteries in the campaign
that's exactly why I still need to dig
into the competitive multiplayer before
I can offer a firm verdict with more
characters to try more customization
options to unlock and many hours of
multiplayer left to play battle bourn's
true potential could still lie ahead so
check back later this week for more
analysis and our final score
haha
I